witnessing today the signature of two
agreements between the European Union
and New Zealand first the signature of
the free trade agreement between the
European commission and New Zealand and
then the association agreement on the
participation of New Zealand to Horizon
Europe the eu's research and Innovation
program we will start with two
statements by the president of the
European commission and the prime
minister of New Zealand president you
have the floor thank you very much and
good morning to everybody the prime
minister
I'm very glad to have you here in
Brussels for such a joyful occasion now
after four years of negotiations today
we're assigning the Free Trade Agreement
it is an ambitious Free Trade Agreement
it is a very well balanced Free Trade
Agreement I think it provides plenty of
opportunities for our respective
businesses
the European Union is already New
Zealand's third biggest trade partner
and with this agreement we should be
able to increase trade between us by 30
percent
and EU investment in New Zealand even by
80 percent so this is excellent news for
the businesses in New Zealand and in the
European Union
as such this deal is already very
special
but it is also a trailblazer because for
the very first time in a trade deal we
have included commitments on the Paris
climate agreement
this reflects our shared Net Zero goals
and it's a real first off
our agreement also facilitates the flow
of data between us
this is a huge potential for our
economies but also important it will do
so in a way that protects individual
rights and privacy
so I think we can be very satisfied and
proud about what we have achieved I
really want to thank Minister O'Connor
and Executive Vice President valdis
tombrovskis
for their very successful and mutual
beneficial negotiations
I also want to thank the whole team of
negotiators for that tireless work big
work big time and I want to thank the
Swedish presidency for its fantastic
work for the council
also many things to you ambassador
for being here to sign on behalf of the
council
this ambitious Free Trade Agreement
reflects the ever expanding scope
of our relationship and indeed we are
expanding our cooperation
today we're also signing the agreement
that allows New Zealand to participate
in our Flagship Innovation program
Horizon Europe
here to remarka First
the first Association agreement with a
country that is not geographically close
to Europe not in our neighborhood but of
course that is very close in so many
other ways to us
Horizon invests 100 billion euros over
seven years in cutting-edge research
it's a fantastic opportunities for your
researchers our researchers and their
participation will further enrich This
research program
we are looking forward to pooling our
best minds and talents so that we can
work together on the next generation of
clean tech of Biotech of digital
projects of medicine you just named it
finally I'm also pleased to announce the
entry into force of the agreement
between New Zealand and europol
dear prime minister
these three agreements bring the
European Union and New Zealand
um even closer
because despite being a world apart
we have so much in common
we are two robust democracies
with the same view of the world and the
same understanding of our
responsibilities
let me thank you for your steadfast
cooperation in support of Ukraine
this includes your support in the United
Nations and of course the alignment on
our sanctions
and we very much welcome New Zealand's
military assistance to our neighbor
under attack
we will have the occasion to discuss
these topics and others in the next days
at the NATO Summit in Lithuania from
Russia's one Ukraine to the rising
tensions in your region the indo-pacific
the geopolitical landscape is
increasingly shifting and uncertain all
the more reasons
to for like-minded partners like us to
strengthen our ties so that we can
navigate the different risks but also
deliver for our citizens thank you very
much and welcome here to Brussels
greetings to you all I'm delighted to be
here in Brussels today with president
vondoline
and after a number of years of disrupted
travel due to the global pandemic it's
great to be back in meeting again in
person
as well as sharing whakapapa or ancestry
links to the European Union many new
zealanders have contemporary ties
through study through travel and through
popular working holiday schemes
our relationship with Europe is
important to us and one that's grounded
in a long-standing historic cultural
connection
we continue to place a premium on our
shared values and Partnerships with
Europe
the EU FTA which we're signing today
reflects those values
it's of huge benefit to both partners
New Zealand exporters will get better
access to the European Union than they
have ever had before
this agreement will generate substantial
new economic opportunities and energize
an already free-flowing two-way
relationship with 20 billion dollars a
year to New Zealand in 2022.
it's also our greenest ever agreement in
a market with increasingly Discerning
consumers
that reflects our products that are some
of the best in the world for
sustainability and it recognizes our
continued path towards lowering Global
emissions
there are groundbreaking outcomes on
climate change and the Paris agreement
and strong commitments in a range of
other areas including labor rights
gender equality and environmentally
harmful subsidies
as well as trade New Zealand and the EU
share a deep commitment to democracy
respect for human rights
Global Peace and security
into the International
rules-based System
we work together on many issues spanning
development in the Pacific climate
change scientific collaboration and
International Security threats
we've joined the EU in condemning
Russia's illegal invasion of Ukraine and
coordinating sanctions and support
as the president has said the europol
agreement signed last year will now
enter into Force this will lead to
Greater collaboration between our law
enforcement agencies to help tackle
serious crime including transnational
organized crime cyber crime and
terrorism
another recent advancement in our
relationship is the New Zealand EU
partnership agreement on relations and
cooperation which entered into Force
last year
it sits out the framework to deepen
Connections in a number of areas
including economic and trade matters
it's science and Innovation
counter-terrorism education and culture
president vonder Lyon and I have also or
will also be witnessing the signing of
the Horizon Europe agreement
which focuses on enhancing our
scientific and trade links
our association will mean deeper
scientific collaboration and for New
Zealand access to Europe's most
significant research program
helping to respond to Major Global
challenges like climate change energy
and health
New Zealand researchers will gain
greater access to professional networks
and world-leading scientific
infrastructure
New Zealand has allocated 50 million
dollars to our association
among other things that will cover the
cost of research Grants awarded to
successful New Zealand research
organizations
our relationship with the European Union
offers such exciting opportunities for
New Zealand
I would encourage all New Zealand
businesses and researchers to make the
most of these opportunities through the
New Zealand EU free trade agreement
through Horizon Europe
and through all that our relationship
with the European Union offers
thank you
thank you thank you
very much
we will now proceed with the signing of
the EU New Zealand Free Trade Agreement
on behalf of the European Union the
agreement will be signed by Mr valis
domboskis Executive Vice President of
the European Commission
on behalf of New Zealand by Mr Damian
O'Connor minister of trade and Export
growth of New Zealand
and on behalf of the Council of
Ministers of the EU by his Excellency
Ambassador Marcos Alonso permanent
representative of Spain
um
they come here yeah nope here was a
picture
[Laughter]
here here
you didn't get the briefing
thank you very much
we will now let our guests leave and we
will proceed
to
we will now proceed to the signing of
the association agreement on the
participation in New Zealand to Horizon
Europe eu's research and Innovation
program
the agreement will be signed by Mr Mark
lumetra EU commission director general
for research innovation
by his Excellency Ambassador Carl Reich
head of mission of New Zealand to the
European Union and his Excellency
Ambassador Marcos Alonso permanent
representative of Spain to the European
Union
foreign
hahaha
thank you very much
to have your attention please
we will now move to the press conference
with Mr value zombroskis and Mr Damian
O'Connor after which we'll take a few
questions if you have any
thank you
so dear Minister O'Connor ladies and
gentlemen
the EU and New Zealand share a very
special relationship I call it being
very close from very far away
uh we are not close Neighbors in terms
of geography but we are close in almost
every other way in terms of politics
culture and values we are Dynamic
exporting economies we are strong
proponents of meaningful climate action
these similarities matter a great deal
in trade relations especially in a world
characterized by growing fragmentation
and geopolitical uncertainty
so with this in mind today's signature
of our Free Trade Agreement represents
an important step forward
first it's important step forward from
our respective trade agendas this deal
represents significant opportunity for
both sides
we estimate that there is a potential to
increase bilateral trade by 30 percent
uh New Zealand exporters will gain
increased access to the EU single Market
offering a range of possibilities in a
dynamic attractive reliable and
predictable economic environment
EU investments in New Zealand could grow
by up to 80 percent uh creating jobs and
growth for New Zealand's economy
we believe our exports to New Zealand
could increase by up to uh four and a
half billion euros per year
so and we are expecting that by removing
tariffs we will save EU businesses
around 140 million euros per year
second this agreement is a true asset
for our rural areas and for our food and
drink producers it will act as a real
stimulus for our rural economies Farmers
on the both sides will help improve
Market access
for instance a tariffs will be
eliminated from day one on key EU
agricultural exports such as pigment
wine and sparkling wine chocolate sugar
confectionery and biscuits
access for Key New Zealand agricultural
products such as wine apples onions or
high quality honey
uh over 2000 uh high quality EU Agri
food products will be protected this
matters because we share a common
understanding that geographical
indications are rural intellectual
property and therefore important drivers
of rural prosperity and job creation
the EU will offer the same protection
for New Zealand products for for example
some of your wonderful and iconic wines
of course are always sensitivities
around agriculture so appropriate
protections are built into the deal on
the EU side sensitivity is concerning
dairy products beef and sheep meat
ethanol and sweet corn are fully taken
into account while still giving
commercially meaningful Market access to
New Zealand producers
third I believe this agreement shows
that trade relationships can make a
positive difference to our climate and
environment
where most Advocates of Greening trade
now we are putting our money where the
amounts is with state of the art green
to trade deal
it contains most ambitious
sustainability commitments ever included
in a free trade agreement
uh let me give you a flavor of just some
of its innovative features
the Paris climate commitments are built
in as an essential element
we have agreed on binding Provisions to
promote core labor rights
we have agreed dedicated chapters or
provisions on sustainable Food Systems
trade and gender equality trade and
fossil fuel subsidies reform
all these items are first in the kind
for the EU
and we have committed to liberalized
trade in green goods and services on the
first day of the application of this
agreement which will support green
transformations of our economies
this agreement also represents an
important step forward for how trade
contribute to digital transition
it has status art rules on a digital
trade including the treatment of
personal data they are ambitious rules
governing data flows
this is crucial for a growing but
geopolitical sensitive economic sector
finally today's signature showcases our
commitment to widening our trade
networks with trusted partners
we already have the deepest and widest
network of the global trade agreements
of any Global player we recently
concluded talks with Kenya and we are
making good progress in in talks with
Australia
and we have a lot more to do we intend
to grow this network to boost our
economic resilience and security
to conclude ambitious trade deals like
this one with reliable and